British Prime Minister Boris Johnson has
announced the closure of all the UK pubs
restaurants cinemas gyms as part of the
containment measures Britain has almost
4,000 confirmed cases but the real
number could be much higher as testing
has so far been limited government
scientists say the virus is spreading
quickly across London and many people
have it ignored advice to stay home last
order is called in an attempt to hamper
the spread of the corona virus despite
government warnings to stay home himself
isolate pubs in the British capital
remained full on Friday the Prime
Minister addressed the country I do
accept that what we're doing is
extraordinary we're taking away the
ancient inalienable right of Freeborn
people of the United Kingdom to go to
the power to help cover the wages of
workers hit by the outbreak the
government is stepping in for the first
time in history government grants will
cover 80 percent of the salary of
retained workers up to a total of 2,500
pounds a month that's just above the
median income the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge made a morale-boosting visit
to a London call centre paying tribute
to the health care workers battling the
crisis meanwhile the Queen in the Duke
of Edinburgh our self isolating at
Windsor Castle despite the new
restrictions and rising death toll
people are maintaining a pragmatic
perspective it's a bit scary because I
drive buses but I just carry on I'm just
carrying on I'm not gonna let it I'm
gonna let it affect me I still have to
suppress apply for to my family for now
the country is grinding to a halt likely
for many months to come
we're now joined by DW correspondent
Charlotte Potts in London Charlotte
scientists believe the outbreak in
London is weeks weeks ahead of the rest
of the country
why didn't authorise act sooner to shut
down the capital well scientists have
been urging Prime Minister Boris Johnson
to react sooner as London has become the
hot spot of infections we just don't
really know how many infections because
testing is only done for severe cases at
the hospital at this point but the death
toll is rising at a faster rate and in
Italy at the moment they're
approximately over a hundred and seventy
deaths in the country recorded so Prime
Minister Boris Johnson always has said
that he would do the right measures at
the right time and yesterday the time
was right to close the pubs and
restaurants theaters and cinemas schools
and nurseries have already shut their
doors yesterday so basically locations
where people can gather but for now this
is only a partial lockdown and for
example shops remain open so we can
expect probably tougher measures to come
in the next days ahead and how are
people reacting to these measures what's
the mood on the streets there in London
well it's extremely divided there are
some people who are still in absolute
denial and who have been going out to
the pub says we saw in the piece earlier
have been enjoying themselves in the
theatres up to yesterday so that is
about to change and it is just slowly
setting in here that the city will quiet
down but I've also talked to those who
can no longer keep calm and carry on who
have been hitting the grocery shops for
example stockpiling has been extreme
here in London I went to the shop
yesterday and already in the morning
there was no fresh milk anymore other
shelves the shelves were absolutely
empty and that is one of the big worries
where is the food going to come from is
is that gonna last for everybody here in
London
and another big worry of the Londoners
is the health care service in comparison
to other European countries intensive
care beds are scarce in this country and
the question that many Londoners are
asking will our health care service be
able to cope if the number of deaths is
rising what about the economic impact of
the coronavirus then what are the
current projections for the UK well it's
going to hit a lot of people very very
severely a lot of people have already
lost their jobs those who work in the
tourism industry for example the
tourists of course are avoiding London
at this point but also those that are
self-employed who now have to live of
the the allowances that the government
gives them the government has announced
some extraordinary measures yesterday to
help those that are affected by the
crisis promising to pay up to 80 percent
of their wages but just to give you a
very quick example the six London
airports for example have said they
might shut down within a matter of weeks
if the government doesn't help out more
so a lot of people very severely
affected by this economic crisis indeed
they W Charlotte pop thanks very much
for the update